regardez en exclusivité la nouvelle
voiture de Volkswagen qui sortira dans
quelques mois alors on la voit ici au
CES elle est complètement camouflé comme
ça ça permet de casser un peu les lignes
et pas se rendre compte cette voiture
c'est Lady 7 i de 7 comme on dit fille
aux États-Unis c'est le véhicule qui
arrive après Lady 5 bref qui vient
compléter cette gamme électrique de
Volkswagen alors pour un côté un peu
plus technique c'est la même plateforme
qu'on a sur les autres modèles de la
gamme c'est-à-dire la plateforme MB le
truc qui peut être intéressant aussi
c'est que l'autonomie ira un peu plus
loin il nous annonce jusqu'à 700 km il
faut dire que le véhicule est quand même
plus gros on le voit plus imposant donc
on aura des batteries plus grosses qui
nous permettront d'aller jusqu'à 700 km
elle va être dévoilée d'ici quelques
mois en France dans le monde entier donc
on en reparlera et on ira peut-être
d'ailleurs l'essayer sur la route est-ce
qu'elle pourrait vous intéresser est-ce
que vous êtes déjà intéressé à
l'électrique et puis pourquoi pas
l'électrique selon Volkswagen dites le
moi dans les commentaires